doctor alex kneslik what's up my brother
how are you my man i'm so pumped for
this
we made it we made it we're ready to go
yes
we did we did and thanks to evan bliss
for making the introduction happen
absolutely thank you for having me i
appreciate i appreciate the invite
yeah and i love everything that you do
in ophthalmology
i'm so fascinated by the eye i'm so
fascinated by what it gives us
as sentient creatures in our environment
and we definitely do not give it the
gratitude and the appreciation
that it deserves and especially those
that uh that take really good care
of our eyes for us that have went
through the medical
literature to know what to do it's a
long road it's a long road and you know
i
we we've gotten a chance to talk about a
lot of this uh without other people
sharing so uh so i'm glad that we can we
could do this in a setting where uh
where other people can can partake yeah
i love starting things off as we sort of
get
into the nitty-gritty of what exactly
the unpacking of things like cataracts
are and lasik is
and all this type of stuff i like to
start things off with our guests asking
them about
their thoughts on some of the more
bigger picture
questions about the nature of our
reality and the nature of consciousness
in general and i'm
pretty excited to hear how you
think about these things so the first
question is
why does reality exist
why does reality exist
uh we'll add this to the uh cheat sheet
that wasn't given pre-screening
um reality
it does exist and we need it
um let's see let me massage this through
you know so so if i took you through
undergrad
and medical school training and and
residency
and fellowship and said you know what
bells does that
you know there's there's a lot of bells
that have been built over the years
uh and what what bells does that ring
why does reality exist well we need it
right we need uh we need to live
in a reality we need to create structure
and a construct that we can operate with
it
oh i like that no no pun intended
i like that answer yeah
as in we need to create
these realities
for us to embed ourselves
in as
explorations i like using that word a
lot in
my like metaphysics nomenclature
is that we undergo
an exploration through this reality
and we sort of use consciousness and
awareness as
a
as a way to experience
the realities
what would you say then is
also the
that the like this one specifically
appears to be so elusive
to the majority of
us which is the very fact of
being aware or the very fact of being
sentient
or conscious in itself just that very
fact maybe
a good way to talk about it is
pre-coloration so before
all of your emotions and feelings and
thoughts and layers of identity of who
you are
and your relationship to objects before
all of that
pre-coloration just the very fact that
you
have awareness
is extremely profound
and that's sort of what we talk about
regarding self-realization
on the program how does that resonate
with you how do you
approach that
i think
you know in um so something that i think
about a lot
uh is that you know there are
some of these
is ways that will uh structure our value
system
right um and if we if we
cycle into you know particularly in
in the hard sciences you know where
where things aren't as
held as in in as high of a regard
um of uh you know the arts and and
culture
and uh you know music and
you know some of these uh the the the
softer things about society
uh you know as you go through
some of the training programs you know
some of those things aren't as uh
they're not pushed as much right but i
think that
you find that societies that function
the best
need those things right because you need
you need to ask some of these questions
to give you the why
because the the what and the how
are are easier questions to answer you
know but
but the why is is a little more elusive
to answer
and i think you find those in some of
these in some of these genres
yeah it's a great way to put it as well
that the
we can almost create a juxtaposition
between
some of these more
harder sciences especially in the sense
of mathematics or
physics and especially physicalism
itself
and then we can sort of juxtapose that
and you can add biology and chemistry
and neuroscience and all the others
to that as well and we can sort of
juxtapose that with
something that's maybe art and music
and philosophy in the humanities
and metaphysics and when you sort of
combine those two
that's where i found
the most integral or
holistic agents
to interact with they get it at a deeper
level
than people that are siloed in either
one of those
and anyone that
realizes the point of art or the point
of music
especially knows that when it creates a
feeling especially something that may
trigger someone else to have more
well-being or to be more
awakened that can be seen as potentially
a piece of art that has a greater
amount of of salience to it and in this
case
in science it can be similar where you
create something
that in the absolute worst poll can be
something like
nuclear weapons or biowarfare malevolent
agi
and on the absolute best poll you can
create something
that eradicates poverty that provides
clean water and abundance
to the majority of civilization so
the synthesis of those two has been such
a key
principle of my life and also of the
lives of
many of the greatest people that i've
been able to sit down with on
on the program i'm glad you brought that
up as well
we'll be revisiting consciousness and
the nature of being in general as we
talk
how did when you were figuring out what
is your north star is your
self-actualization
so the self-realization is the
realization
that we were talking about earlier of
that
that god that source that we are
and then the self actualization is sort
of the
expression of that into the world and us
being
unique expressions of it as these
individual conscious agents
in that so you got to figure out what
that was for you
and how did it hone in over time on
ophthalmology
well i you know i think one of the most
beautiful things about medicine
is that it is not
an exact science right it is in its
purest sense
a blend of the science and the art
right and so you know a lot of what you
do
as as a physician uh as a as a surgeon
when when you interact with patients uh
when you do
you you perform these these procedures
you know there
there is a lot of art in
the work right so i you know and i think
for that reason
you know you you find that a lot of
physicians they get
um they they feel a lot of uh
satisfaction out of their work because
there's there is this expression in it
right it's not
um and you know it and i think we've
actually spoken about this before you
know when you look at
like the concept of flow right and like
the flow mind state
and you know things that that give
people this experience where
you know you're so engrossed in
in a uh in an action in something where
you lose all track of time
you're you're totally focused on this
thing um
and you know the great joy that people
experience
in flow uh you know the uh in it
the the guy um it's the university of
chicago
uh psychology professor uh mahali
yeah that uh um yeah you know the book
is phenomenal but
uh you know his last name continues he
continues
and uh you know when you look at
some of the rules for for flow and some
of the
the actions that tend to predispose
someone
to experiencing this this profound
experience that people
you know talk about whether they're uh
you know uh
uh rock climbers i think are
one of the ones that uh you know when he
goes through you know people that
experience a lot of flow they're the
people in athletics people
um that in these high skill activities
uh
one of the fields that he continues to
go back to
over the course of the entire book is
surgeons um
because you know there there are so many
aspects that are pro uh flow
you know this flow experience that
you're totally engrossed in this
um this thing that you're doing um and
and i can tell you that
you know you you look at uh you know
studies on a lot of long-time surgeons
and they talk about how
you know they get so much enjoyment out
of the work they would do it for free
um you know the the the act of the the
work
is that powerful um
so then you add on top of that you know
the layer of what you're able to do
for the patients what you're able to do
for society what you're able to do for
your community
um you know i think that i knew
some of those things going in um but now
being on the other side of it
uh it's it's powerful you know it's
really powerful i
i i i find myself experiencing that in
my work
on a daily basis
i love that i love how you went into
flow and i love how you give the example
that we just came from which is the
synthesis of that art and science
as what in this case is what you
feel as you undergo the process of
being in service to helping
augment people's lives and
yeah the amount of in these scenarios
just like here with
interviewing it's so important to
completely be present and that same
thing in athletics it's the same thing
in surgery
you cannot be thinking about the past
you cannot be thinking about the future
you have to be there and ensuring that
what you're doing
is of peak performance and also that
you're scientifically you're following a
methodological procedural system
lasik cataracts any of these scenarios
yet as we've had many physicians on the
program
and even some as my personal mentors
have talked to me about how
the art is actually so critical as you
undergo this methodological protocol
because you're going to encounter
so many times something that needs that
that happens off protocol that
and you're going to have to improvise
well and and that's actually something i
find
um was the biggest transition for me
going from training to you know trainee
to uh completing training and now being
kind of out on my own in private
practice
you know when you're in med school you
take you take a lot of bubble tests
right and bubble tests have a b c and d
right
and you can you can find the right there
is an answer
and the answer is a b c or d um but
when you get out um you know and you
have this patient in front of you have
this problem in front of you
um sometimes it's not any of those four
um
and you still you still have to make a
call you still have to make a judgment
call
and that's that's where the experience
comes in that's where the mentorship
comes in
um that's where the art comes in uh and
and i think that that's
that's kind of the fun part oh yeah
yeah that's that's a huge part of the
fun and then i would also
assume that from so many of the
conversations that we've had that
there's something that's
this is very similar with what i get
from the program as well
in the sense of my goodness
when the guest leaves at the end of the
program and it's just like
wow like i really blossomed on the
program
thank you for that you know this is
similar with when you heal someone when
you augment someone's life
when they have something that's a
pathology that's formed in their eye
that's satisfaction that you get exactly
yeah cause then they're like
thank you so much doctor thank you
because it's the vision my goodness
man you you had that hilarious little
instagram post that you had recently
made for thanksgiving
where there was a little flying turkey
inside of the
eye for cataracts in this case um
and i still think it's funny it's it is
funny
it's so thick it's funny but like if you
can try and empathize
and imagine the
let's see we actually have the we have
the numbers we have the numbers right
here
um so
cataract surgery is the most common
procedure performed by the
ophthalmic surgeon this year
3.6 million cataract procedures
will be performed in the united states
and more than 20 million will be
performed worldwide
so the number of patients visually
handicapped by cataract globally
increases every year
so the reason why i bring this up
is because before you know it it's going
to be happening to
your parents or you know downline
you and me and so
to sort of have an idea of like
this vision that we have right now that
we're so
you know the body being in such good
health
it's like we
just no problem go about the day
but as soon as we have some sort of
ailment in our like knee or our lower
back or
especially in our vision if we had that
little fuzzy
opaqueness forming in this pocket of our
vision
it's disastrous once the health
deteriorates like that and we just want
to
rebound as quickly as we can well and
it's
it's a uh it hits deep
right it hits deep because it starts to
make us
question um you know our own
mortality right and you know what
you know how how how many days do we
have here is this
are things starting to change for me um
and you know and i
obviously don't don't know your your
medical history but you know i've had
certain you know i've gotten sick before
i've had surgeries before
um you know i i had lasik myself
so you know to be in a position where
you know i do this procedure
i know exactly how it's supposed to go i
know exactly how the post-op period goes
i know exactly how everything how how
everything should go
and you know and it's still scary you
know
and it's it's still scary to be um on
the other side of that where now
you know you're you're the patient um
and
you know i think that that's that's
actually been one of the most powerful
experiences for me to have been on both
ends
right because i i think it now you know
there there are some things that i think
you you have to experience yourself
to really be able to connect with people
on um and
uh you know i think that that's been one
of the most powerful things for me
uh you know as a physician as a surgeon
to
to have been to have experienced some of
those things so that now when i
when i see you know my patients and and
the trust that people put in me
uh you know to know to know what that
felt like
it's cool that you got
lasik and that enabled you to have that
perspective that you now have it's
actually really important in a sense
for the
person that's undergoing the
the surgery in this case maybe it's me
that's undergoing the surgery
to know that the physician the surgeon
in the case has been through this
procedure
as a patient themselves so that they
know what it looks like before
during after and they know
like you're dealing with a lot of the
different combinations and iterations of
what
each individual person undergoes with
how they feel about the entire process
and so now you're becoming more
agile and you have a greater catalog of
people's responses
in undergoing this process that you can
navigate more swiftly
and that's that's super duper important
well and i think um just to touch back
on the uh the art part
you know i think that also becomes a
part of the the shepherding
right you know where you know you are
there
to not just perform a procedure
right but you know we are we're not
robots right
we're not automatons um but you're
you're performing a procedure
on a person who's going to feel some
sort of way about this procedure
um and you know you are being entrusted
not just with
their surgery and and performing well
but also
being able to shepherd you know that
that emotional journey for them because
it's stressful time right
um and you know i think that the
how you interact with that person how
you you make them
you make sure that they feel heard you
make sure that they feel like they can
trust you
um you know so many of those things can
make
this experience you know you go very
positively
and become you know an extremely you
know a
a liberating experience where you come
in with a problem
and you find somebody that you trust
that you connect with they're able to
fix this problem and you can go off on
the road you you
know you continue to go off on your own
um or or something that becomes more
scary
right and you don't have the right
person there to kind of shepherd you
through this
um and you know i keep going back to the
the trust thing but i think that it's uh
it's so it's so important
lumped into art in a sense we could add
emotional intelligence
absolutely and that's what this is it's
it's the ability to navigate
all of the different expressions of
humans that are coming
in to undergo these surgical processes
because if you can navigate them with
love
and peace and joy and compassion
and wisdom my goodness the whole process
see this is the type of stuff that i
love is that
you know that's why you're here is
because you see it from a scientific and
an artistic perspective
and i think it's very important to help
hopefully
bring into the hearts of others not only
that our physicians
currently and that are aspiring
physicians is
picking up that emotional intelligence
picking up that art
along the way that spirituality along
the way
as you dive into the science
is going to be super critical and i love
the way that you
also explained it like abcd well what
about
when the off protocol
experience comes you know is the
is maybe there should be more practice
we've
we've talked about this before but we'll
we'll get into this in more detail but
sort of
you know what does the future of
physician education
actually look like is there going to be
a module
for a deeper module for emotional
intelligence and
art and spirituality is there going to
be a module for
the
the ability to sort of go beyond the
existing
infrastructures maybe it's something
like tool making
like tool making itself as a module like
maybe that is something that
becomes something that is really
powerful because how often does
out of the 450 ophthalmologists that are
graduating every single year in the
united states
how many of them are thinking well
how can i build something that is
potentially better than lasik or the
existing solving
of the issues with cataracts could
i actually push the edge of
ophthalmology
that's never been done before but like
when are we trained to be
that style of thinkers in medical school
would it be a question
yeah well and even um you know if you
think about medical training um
and even medicine as a culture
like right it's not tech right
like like it's it's not entirely right
it's not it's
it's not silicon valley iterative right
yeah pool tables and
and and kitchens full of yeah
snacks from your vegan local
and and i would actually say that you
know i think what what is going to be
interesting moving forward is as tech
companies
are getting involved in medicine yeah
right google is starting to get involved
in medicine
and right and as as
some of these uh these other approaches
philosophically right these different
philosophical approaches to solving
problems
um start to get involved in the field
uh i'm curious i would say that i'm i'm
curious to see how things go because you
know i think if you look at physicians
um you know it's on a sweeping
generalization
right on a sweeping generalization a lot
of physicians
you know and what i think that the field
is selected for is
not or is not people that are inherently
risk takers
right right yeah you know so you know
because like right you
do you want your physician to be a risk
taker right you know
so so there are there are some there are
some characteristics
that you know if you were to look at
things that are
that are good for innovation you know
sometimes
aren't wouldn't align with building an
entire
infrastructure of medical doctors
right so you know
how how you um
play at two of these polls right where
on one end
you know you want to be progressive and
you want to innovate and you want to try
new things you know on the other end of
that poll
you know you i don't know if you want
somebody necessarily coming in
and just trying some new procedure on
you that you know wasn't well studied
that's why we have the fda
that's why we have all this stuff um you
know speaking of
i think i'm gonna be getting vaccine uh
this week
uh which is which is exciting um you
know i think it's it's kind of a medical
marvel if you really look at what
uh what happened over the course of the
last year and now here we are
uh you know in all honesty i i actually
you know after spending all this time in
medicine and surprised myself that uh
that that this you know that they were
able to to pump this thing out before
um before the end of the year i think
it's it's really you know a testament to
how far you know medicine has come and
what uh what we're able to create so
you know that i was slightly unrelated
but i
i just remembered that i have that
coming up tomorrow
something that would be great
would be just a brief small hit back on
that ball would be
just like keeping the general public
in a loop about
the actual iterative process that
science has
undergone with creating
the vaccine on a very
video log level so
creating video logs of the actual
process
and the actual ability of
the vaccine to
create the solution that tackles the
coronavirus
and making it actually
building truly going through the hard
process of building the trust
it's a hard process like you said did
you kept going back to trust
it's the it's that main thing i'm just a
small on a small point there
there's a lot of aspects to these like
next generation
you gave the two poles which are great
we need them both
yet we need visionaries
really more than ever we need
visionaries
and a lot of the
existing collegiate and university
infrastructures
are in a sense very much
like a straight jacket
and that is
beneficial in some ways and it's
detrimental
in others and the hybridization
of the information technology
smartphones virtual reality
era is coming it's already very much
here with being able to become an
auto died act and teach yourself
from the internet which is incredible
but that's creating a whole
economic
process for the education sector that
it's never experienced before because
it's always been a gatekeeper in many
ways
and it's no longer and same thing in
media
we have this now which there's no longer
a gatekeeper
this is it this is it's a democratized
technology that's now here
meritocracy those with the most
competence
should be the ones that ideally are the
ones that are
aiming to help lead
the world in tackling the biggest
challenges and maximizing well-being
will you rank order for us i want the
rank order
in ophthalmology
the
first principle in a sense
that again we very quickly forget the
profundity of
is that you want to retain the health of
the eye in its peak
capacities
and then now would we say that
ideally you would want to do something
potentially like
you know retain what your
the capacity of your eyes are like when
you're
you know maybe 18 years old like the 18
year old eye
and you want to basically keep that
through your
20s 30s 40s 50s 60s 70s 80s and beyond
like
having that even even 10 years i'm 28
now
over the last 10 years oh my goodness
has my eyesight deteriorated in so many
ways i
use i used to be able to sit at the back
of the
class or the presentation and have no
problem with
watching what was being presented now i
either have to sit in the middle and
squint really hard or i have to sit all
the way in the front row which i like
doing anyway
to actually be able to see it so there's
sort of a deterioration plus
with the era of
these devices our our
focal range in itself
has become you know
if this is even 12 inches or something
12 or 24 maybe inches
and that
and or the computer screens when we're
working for eight
hours you know sitting and looking at
something that's two feet from us and
longer right
you know because because it's you know
you're you're on your phone
in the morning eight hours at work then
you go home and you're
on your phone at home and you're
scrolling through instagram
uh and uh so yeah i mean uh screen time
is uh is up and it's up in a big way and
i don't know that it's going anywhere
all right um
you know the uh you know
it as you mentioned you know the so so
a couple uh a couple things start to
happen as we get older
right um so we already kind of touched
on
touched on cataracts a little bit so so
when we look inside
inside the eye there's this natural lens
you're born with this lens it comes in
clear
this is a good time to bring up some of
the visuals yeah okay excellent let's
let's bring up those visuals
that's uh yeah i think it's like this
this one
right here this one all right okay cool
oh oh yeah yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] oh this one's dope i'm so excited
for you guys all right yeah check that
out
so we got a healthy lens so so left and
now that's the cataracts
right so on our on our left side so that
that's our eye and cross section
um and if you look inside the eye uh
you have you have this healthy lens so
you know when you look at someone's eyes
and you see their eye color that's the
iris so you blue eyes green eyes
something like that
so that's your iris color behind the
iris
is where that lens sits and as we get
older
uv related changes age-related changes
all fibers in that lens start to change
their orientation and light doesn't pass
through them as well
so as light doesn't pass through them as
well it becomes cloudy
it's almost like uh like driving a car
with a dirty windshield
um and sometimes the windshield can get
so dirty you can't see out of it at all
um and and that's a cataract and so so
you know as cataracts begin to develop
they impact their vision
and um you know sometimes there's a host
of reasons why cataracts develop but
usually they're age related usually
you know i'm kind of speaking in general
terms but we're talking
60s 70s or so when this starts to really
kind of impact your vision there's some
exceptions
you know if you were on prednisone
you're on steroids for
asthma copd something like that trauma
you know there's some times where
uh and sometimes even congenital
cataracts are some babies that are born
with cataracts
but really there's a fix for this so we
go in
we actually make a little hole on the
front side the cataract actually sits
inside of a little bag
we make a hole in the front side of that
bag we take the cataract out
and then put a new lens inside of the
bag
and uh and it's kind of crazy so if you
if you look at the back
story on that um so back in
uh back in world war ii uh so these
these lenses are made out of a
particular plas plastic that's like pmma
um and sort of offshoot of plastic and
during world war ii there were some
fighter pilots
um that the the windshields on their
fighter jets
had uh had shattered and little
fragments of this
this plastic the same plastic fell into
their eyes
and they found that there was no
inflammatory response
you know their eyes handled the plastic
just fine it was just kind of hanging
out in there so that was actually
how the the first intraocular lenses
were made out of that same material
so now you know it's sort of involved
and uh there's another offshoot of this
this plastic that's very because the
initial ones um they didn't fold very
well so the lenses we use now
they actually fold they basically taco
up so we can make like these small
little incisions in the cornea 2.4
millimeters 2.7 millimeters
um and the lens sort of circles into
this little taco and you can actually
inject it through and then once it goes
inside then it sort of
opens up um fills the it fills where
that old lens used to be
and now you can see
oh my goodness okay wow
i just i adore vision so
much and as we were saying at the
beginning
of the episode it's such an important
aspect
to sentience to awareness to
consciousness
as we immerse ourselves in these
creations
the vision component in this three space
with one time
is so critical and
it
it is the top
sense in many ways the top
way for us to understand
our environment and the other agents
in it and well it's so much of
connection right it's so much of
connection right
like we are we are social creatures
right we're social creatures
and and so much of communication being
non-verbal
right uh all these cues visual cues you
know how someone feels about you facial
expression
you know all these things that that are
uh you know how
how individuals they bond with each
other how you know kids bond with
parents
um you know friends bond with each other
families keep in touch
you know there's so many of these
aspects of
you know human life or communities that
are dependent on us
being able to to to see and to perceive
yes now
are we correct to say that
on the most
exterior so the furthest
on the left in these images
that
is the cornea
yes is the
what appears to be maybe a couple
like a hundred or maybe a couple
thousand
cell depth like on average about 550
microns
550 microns give or take
yeah so so cornea being so the front
most part on the ai that you can see
there so
so like you if you look at like your
your colors so i can see like your eyes
are kind of hazel right yeah
um if you were to poke yourself in the
eye you wouldn't actually hit the
colored part you hit your cornea first
cornea first
um and so the cornea is going to be so
the two main refractive powers for the
eye
right so when somebody is nearsighted
somebody's farsighted
although in astigmatism those are things
that are all interplays
between the lens and the cornea and so
those are the two things that are that
are going to be refracting and focusing
light to land on your retina so you can
see
and the iris is also like a
muscle yeah there are some muscles in
the iris but you don't really
the the muscles that are responsible for
using the lens is a different muscle
so there's actually you can see on the
little picture there yeah so if you look
at the lens
there's a bunch of these like little
those little fibrils thing there they're
called zonules
so those go to the ciliary body so that
that's actually so while there are
muscles within the iris there's actually
a muscle
called the ciliary body that sits around
the lens so when i
you know look at you and then i look
over to take a look at my watch
right that cillary body is contracting
and that's going to allow the lens
inside my eye to swell
so in the same way that when you take uh
you look with like a magnifying glass
that's basically what you the lens
inside of your eye is doing so that
that's called accommodation
so the ability to accommodate
accommodation and dynamicism
yeah right so the dynamic process you
start to lose it
in around your 40s so the uh the magic
uh or at least the technical name for
that is presbyopia
presbyopia right so that's uh you know
when you look at
um so like my you know my dad has these
reading glasses he just kind of like
hangs out on his nose
um and that so that's basically what
he's doing is he's creating
that accommodation so you know when he
looks at something across
um and but he needs a little bit of that
extra power well he lost some of that
accommodation
so now he looks through that little lens
that's sitting out on the
not on the nose so now you know when you
look at your watch it comes into focus
so that's why all these plays that we do
you know cataract surgery with the lens
inside the eye
uh refractive surgery on the cornea all
those things are
are changing where these light beams are
landing
so you know if you're if you're
nearsighted so myopia
means that the light beams are landing
in front of the retina so they actually
land inside of the eye
um if you're hyperopic so that's
farsighted the light beams are actually
landing behind the retina so this is all
optics right yeah and
what we're we're basically you know
manipulating
with uh this new lens that i put inside
for cataract surgery the resurfacing on
the cornea we're actually changing
how those light beams come together so
if you're you're myopic we can actually
change the light beams land a little bit
further back
so if those light beams land a little
bit further back now you can see clearly
yeah yeah so
the refractive elements are
cornea lens and small amount of
the iris and doesn't do it not
refractive
more the muscle contract so it's like
the iris can act a little bit more like
an aperture
in a sense yes yeah because i've
noticed that there's many of these
really brilliant scientific
illustrations
of the the uh
the pupil right now under these intense
lights being very very small
and then once we turn off the lights
it's so cool how
the dynamicism and it looks like it's
like that muscle of
that iris that almost lets the
pupil open up under the darker to take
in more light in the darker environments
yeah
those are like some of the coolest like
child
science museum experiments to have kids
undergo
it's amazing right you don't think about
any of this stuff it just does it on its
own
yeah so um
now the cornea
and the lens have most of the refractive
components
so then the cornea
as we talk about cataracts it looks as
though we're talking about the lens and
not the cornea so then most of the time
the cornea is fairly okay up through
the later parts of life it's the lens
itself
that gets most of the issue typically
yeah i mean there's all sorts of
problems that can happen with
um and so i do corneal transplants as
well so
you know the there's all sorts of issues
that can develop with the cornea if you
have
you know trauma you get some scar you
know right now
now you've got these refractive beams
that are supposed to be coming in but
there's a scar
on a certain part of the cornea so
that's gonna end up distorting the image
it sometimes gives you you know
sometimes impacts the vision you know if
the scar is right in the middle you
can't see through it at all so
you know what do we do we can do corneal
transplant basically punch out that part
of the cornea put in a new cornea um
yeah changing out the windshield on the
car
yeah um so but i'd say for
if we're speaking sort of in general
terms you know cataracts happen to
basically everybody who lives long
enough
um so you know that that's a almost
expected
age-related change um cornea is more so
uh it's a typically end up doing just
fine
now is the material that's used in the
cornea replacement a similar material
that's used in the lens replacement or
different no different materials
so so corneal trans so transplants are
all donor tissue
donor tissue right so when you you know
you look at your driver's license
and your organ donor um that's uh that's
where we get it
whoa so all all of the
can you use all of the just the cornea
but can you use all of the
can you use parts of the cornea that are
also
outside of the just um so does the
cornea also wrap
around beyond the iris no just so
at that so basically the point at which
you see the white part of the eye
that's called the sclera sclera the
white part of the eye
but is that also the white part of the
eye on the exterior is called the sclera
as well
is that not still the cornea that's
wrapping even so so cornea is only
sitting over the iris it's only sitting
over the iron right so you see how
on the image there's like a little bit
of a dome that dome is it right the dome
is the core
what's outside of the corner what's that
like very thin layer outside of
the cornea so over top of the sclera is
the conjunctiva
so that what is it the what the
conjunctiva the conjunctiva so like when
you get pink eye
right so pink eye you know the fancy
name for that is conjunctivitis
conjunctivitis all right so inflammation
brain conjunctiva itis inflammation
yeah yeah well i'm i was curious about
that as well because of that
exterior most larry because you said we
poked the cornea
but then technically we first hit the
the what is it the contract so
conjunctiva doesn't grow over the cornea
or at least you don't want it to oh so
it only is over
the sclera yeah oh so then technically
in this
image that
the cornea itself
potentially shouldn't shouldn't have
that that exterior most layer
over it it doesn't yeah it doesn't yeah
so the conjunctiva
ends at the start of the cornea okay
yeah okay see that's sort of okay
cool okay cool maybe they're just yeah
illustrating it here this way okay
cool okay so there's that and then now
you said that within this stuff this
stuffs me so fascinating so i'll
unpack this me too
yeah as you as you were saying actually
you first said this and i kind of tabled
it in
in my mind i knew i wanted to come back
to it which is now
what exactly is the deterioration that
is occurring
in the lens itself is that
a a cellular malfunctioning
that so it's thought to be related to
collagen fibers
so so the collagen fibers um
in the lens are in a particular
arrangement that allow light to pass
through them
and if that elaine arrangement changes
then the light no longer passes through
sort of in the same way like if you
think about like sunglasses
like right like how do sunglasses where
it's like polarizing
and so so all polarized lenses do
is they're they're blocking light that
goes
through you know in a particular
arrangement and while letting other
light through
right so if you have you know polarized
lenses that look like this
light beams that go this way will pass
and they'll pass through and they'll
keep going but light beams that are
going this way will hit against this and
they won't go through
now is the way that we're aiming to
investigate this by
taking the diseased
lenses and then bringing them under
high-powered microscopy in order to
identify
that it's a collagen fiber
yeah i uh there's people smarter than me
that like i love this stuff
that got up okay alex is going to get
these people on our program so we can
talk to them
yeah yeah but uh but they are around
yeah and they've got
they've got fancy tools and microscopes
and uh and they wrote the books that i
read
yeah yeah totally totally i love i was
fascinated by stuff like this
yeah i'm also fascinated by seeing if
there's a way to
we talked at the very beginning as the
first principle of like
retaining 18 year old
youthful homeostatic capacity of the
eye as sort of the first principle and
like my
one of my thoughts would be like well
what interventions do i need just like
we do with our
cars and with our jet engines we have
all these sensor suites that are all
over them
but with our health we don't actually
do a
a more
you know i use this this image a lot
which is
from chapter six of high level
perception called ai coach and
it's just like we don't have this
constant data visualization
of our biometrics because if we did
we could tweak our
health at even the cellular level maybe
even at the metabolomic level
that could
put us back in balance
which then prevents the development of a
pathology
i love stuff like this and i would
wonder what would be required
for us to
keep a 18 year old
even like potentially 2015
vision
when i'm 28 38 48 58 68 etc
and like what would those interventions
potentially look like when i'm
you know like like bringing a car in and
you get your
oil changed and your and the tires
are rotated and the
maybe you change the serpentine belt all
these different aspects which are all
changing as we move to electric vehicles
which is hilarious
but a lot a lot of it is at least
uh but there's over there software
updates there's a lot of other things
that happen with those
but still in this case it would be like
how can we potentially make our
health care system more around that
principle rather than addressing the
pathology when it happens when we're
in this case approximately you know 60
or
or 70 years old
you know i
if i were to address it on a on a big
scale i would tell you
that as a general principle um
you know we address the pathology
because
we can address the pathology right you
know
because if you think about how you
structure
the study right like how you know we
there there is a limited amount of time
there's a limited amount of funding
there's limited enrollment patience
right you know what is the question
right you must have your hypothesis
right so
and then once you have all of those
things
you also have to have you know the
statistical power
to make an assertion about something
right so you know if you can't
how big of a study would you have to
have if you were just going to bring
people in off the street
and follow them for 50 years right to
see
right you know the the logistics of
doing some of that stuff
um is it just becomes impractical right
so
so what can we do you know we can take a
disease state
um and look for patterns right look for
correlations
look for you know macular degeneration
more common in smokers
right so what do we say if you start to
develop macular degeneration
stop smoking right heart disease same
thing
you know that that's kind of what we
would medicine as a whole has been able
to to sort of play back from the
the subset of individuals that got the
disorder because
you know because ultimately if you were
to run through the population as a whole
most people you know have
most people end up being relatively
healthy right and you know as
you have a you know a subset of the
population that develops some sort of a
particular ailment
um you know the you have to
you know structure it in a way to where
you can you can study
this um so you know i think i can tell
you you know
a question that i get asked from from
friends of mine a lot is the uh the blue
blockers
right yeah you know that uh and i and it
and it comes up a lot
um and uh you know i have i have a bunch
of friends you know
doctors as well you know one of my good
friends um who's a neurosurgeon
um was actually just texting me the
other day asking you know should i get
some blue blockers
um and uh and i sent her the the nih
study um that's you know that that says
that i can't comment right you know
could do
do blue blockers do anything um maybe
i mean you know but i can tell you that
there's no
i don't know of any published data that
says that it does something
this is yeah you're right that it's
really important to do these in these
randomized controlled trials to respect
the scientific method
and its integrity i completely agree
with you there
i also realized that a lot of these
things are very intuitive
like in the sense like a lot of us
especially in a very generic sense we
grew up
uh over biological evolution with the
sun
so there's a circadian rhythm and so
there's that is generically speaking
and then in the case of potentially this
youthful homeostatic capacity is just
something like an
18 year old and their ability to
bounce back from an injury and their
speed at which their cells rejuvenate
and their body
heals is just incredibly
quick versus even being in your later
20s or
later 30s you already have a slowed down
pace and so we kind of
know in a sense intuitively the sort of
idea of bioenergetics in terms of the
mitochondria's ability to
turn that glucose into atp and power our
body we know the aspects of
our of our exposomics
and that's a whole new emerging field
which is fascinating which is
the way that the environment affects
the the genomics and the the actual body
the
organism the creature itself
there's all these sort of emerging
fields
that are
are trying to answer the
questions in a scientific method
yet intuitively we know
that there's a balanced
state there's a state of
equilibrium that the even through
feedback
like the the pancreas and the blood
sugar homeostasis as well secreting
insulin or glucagon there's
all of these sort of processes
that what is the optimal like 18 year
old
state of the entire biometric of the
body
and first that and then second how do we
make the interventions beyond
that sort of 18 year old peak state
including things
like the entire health of the
eye to especially as we go into the
like your friends pinging you what about
blue light or like we just talked about
a little bit
earlier like these devices themselves
because
they're so close and like you said then
there's the computers and we're entering
into the virtual reality
era as well and so we have to
we have to like i've even heard you know
the
there are some ophthalmologists that
have talked about sort of these cycles
that ins when you when you are looking
at a device to basically take
a short period of time maybe just a
minute or two
every half hour or whatever to just go
look at like
a tree that's really far away from you
and just hone in and focus on that
so you're kind of in a sense you're
working that focal point
from something that's really close to
something that's really far it's like
doing
well by doing that right what you're
doing is you're relaxing
that little muscle inside your eye all
right so there's that that little
cilliary body that's working over time
um in order for you to stay focused at
things up close
you know how do you relax your ciliary
body you look at something far away
and you let it relax yeah
so some you know i i fatigue um
you know i strained a lot of that uh you
know the theory on that
being related to you know you working on
that tiny tiny little ciliary body for
15 hours a day
right and if you look at it on uh you
know on a long term scale
right you know when you are scouring the
savannah
right as society has changed as the
needs have changed
right you know our ciliary body um
you know that may have been very
beneficial
uh you know out in out in the savannah
uh
you know looking for food running from
predators uh you know
i'm not sure if it was built for the the
nine to five office job
yeah and that also interplays
really deeply with what we were talking
about before we started which was that
back in the day of those days especially
in our early biological evolution
if you had a scenario of
being born with ailment
of the eye the likelihood that you would
be
preyed on would be very high um
and then we solved that with glasses
that was kind of one of the big
corrections was optics and glasses which
was very interesting
but now like we talked about we are
really
becoming gods and it's really beautiful
because i love the idea of thinking
about that surgical precision
where you can walk us through this
example with cataracts
so you said that there's a very small
sort of incision that occurs
and the lens itself
is the lens with cataracts is taken
out and then there's this the modern day
technology is
a little taco roll-up of it and then
having that injected and it naturally
unfolding
let's talk about that surgical process
let's talk about
the material that that is made of let's
talk about who manufactures it
let's talk about how much this costs
let's talk about all this so
you know one of the things i love about
um you know the art of medicine is some
of the history of medicine
right you know that whole saying about
you don't know where you're going until
you know where you came from
um and you know so so if you want to
talk about today that has a very
profound spiritual
meaning as well yeah go ahead the uh
to to circle back on the the innovation
spirit
uh so you know modern day cataract
surgery
uh was pioneered by a guy uh charles
kellman in like the 70s
and you know surgery before what the
current technique was
um you know there were these big
incisions you used to take out
i mean first you go way back back back
um you know original cataract surgery
was
uh was couching i don't know if you've
heard that term before no
so couching um was basically sticking a
needle in the eye
and taking that cataract and then just
pushing it out of the way
like right so no lens you know it was
just moving this cataract out of the way
um so as you can imagine it didn't work
great
you know it didn't work great because
now you don't have a lens in the eye
you've got a lens kind of dangling
around somewhere else
high rates of infection inflammation all
sorts of issues
um and but you know once upon a time you
know that that's
that's what you had right so you know
then you get to a point where you start
taking these lenses out
whole um so you used to it was called
extra cap where basically you'd take the
entire lens out
um and uh and this guy so
dr kellman um discovered the current
technique which is called facal
emulsification where we're actually
using
a little ultrasound probe um so you go
in through this incision
and you're using a little ultrasound
probe to actually use
sound waves to break up the cataract and
bring and and it comes out through this
tubing so that's what allows you to do
it under the small incision
but as you as you can imagine when when
kelman first started
uh doing some of this he was doing it
like like in the basement
of columbia you know people thought he
was crazy um
you know so so the community right the
community as a whole
thought he was nuts like what's this guy
doing with his little ultrasound probe
um so you know now what what's
you know the the the standard worldwide
right
um was was really you know pioneered by
uh by this guy who believed in i
believed in this technique so you know
it's um
it's a little bit the ultrasound probe
is still the
that's what i do yeah that's what i did
last week yeah exactly
you know i mean i mean of course the 50
years it's been improved
yeah you know the technology has changed
and the machines that we use but the
very essence
of how you're doing the surgery um you
know was really started by
this guy so minor incision
and then the ultrasound probe breaks
up the lens right so yeah and then you
use
that like kind of vacuum it out to suck
it out yeah so it's a combination so
it's this probe
um that you know is basically breaking
things up in combination with with
vacuum vacuuming right in combination
with an irrigation so there's actually
like a tubing
because you have to keep this area open
right so
oh yeah yeah right so you have to have
like a working space so the other
graphic that we have the
the lens stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
pull up the lens polyphones
um so the so as you go in you
so you break up this cataract you take
this cataract out it's coming out
through this ultrasound probe and then
you inject so these little lenses
um are foldable so like i mentioned
before
you know this is a uh it's an offshoot
of plastic
okay that that the uh that the lenses
are made out of
and they come in through this little
injector and the lens will kind of taco
up in this little injector
you can go through this small your right
like two and a half millimeter incision
um and then you put it back in the place
of where the old lens was
and then you close things up a lot of
these surgeries were actually doing
sutureless
even you know you can a lot of these
incisions are self-sealing the way that
we make them
so there's a particular technique where
we're shelving and kind of beveling
these
these incisions so they kind of close on
their own no sutures
um and i mean it's really you know
current
uh cataract surgery technique i mean a
lot of surgeons are doing this stuff 5
10 15 minutes something like that for a
case um
five ten fifteen minutes total time for
door yeah yeah and am i asleep
yeah so you know it's uh so a lot of
things are done kind of uh
kind of twilight um you know you're not
really asleep you're not really awake a
little bit of
anesthesiology yeah look you know most
people have you know
either an anesthetist or an
anesthesiologist there so
you know people are comfortable anxiety
is under good control you know if things
are uncomfortable we always kind of
tweak things
there's like a mechanism that like keeps
the eye
open yeah it's like that uh what's the
the like hannibal
uh uh yeah there's like a little little
eyelid holder eyelid holder
um i'm just awake the whole time while
this is happening
i mean you're you're you're pseudo
pseudo-awake yeah yeah you're pseudo
it's a twilight yeah yeah it's kind of
twilight it's uh you know happy time
yeah um but you know most uh most
patients we finish up with surgery and
and
most common thing i hear is is that was
it that was yeah that's it
that's so interesting that it's at that
pace now and what's the
cost of the operation now um
so you know honestly the the the
reimbursement
has been fluctuating yeah and you know
the
so i mean the the surgeon fee as i
you know and this is where some of the
the the business side of medicine i'm
still kind of learning myself to be
honest um you know the
how it it kind of gets split between the
facility fee
so there's like a surgery center fee um
there's a surgeon fee
and and all of that also gets varied
there's a lot of
modifications on the surgery so you know
sometimes we
we do astigmatism correction as a result
you know it
kind of bundled into this sometimes
there's a laser used to do certain
certain parts of the procedure called a
femtosecond laser
sometimes we're inserting lenses that
are what are called multifocal lenses
where
you know they're giving you some of this
accommodation back you get a little bit
of distance you get a little bit of near
it's actually little rings that can get
implanted um into these lenses that'll
different rings stan um end up focusing
the light beams at different focal
lengths
um and so those are called multifocal
lenses uh
and uh that's what we were talking about
earlier with correcting
myopia and other um to a degree yeah
to a degree but but the accommodation is
the part that you're kind of getting
back with some of this technology
yeah i see and in all of these things
end up you know
change you know there's a different cost
that's associated with it each one and
and then
would it be generally like out of pocket
like no insurance is this like a ten
thousand dollar procedure or something
or like five thousand or something
honestly i wouldn't we don't even know
yeah who made who manufactures this do
you know
yeah so there's a couple big companies
um you know there was a
a big company called uh amo that was
bought by johnson johnson
um so so jnj um does
a lot of lenses now bash and loam is
kind of in the game as well
and then another company uh al khan um
that's owned by novartis
so those are kind of like the three the
three big players if you will there's a
couple other
um other ones but the uh those are kind
of the the
i'd say the big three kind of lens
manufacturers i wonder
if there's any public
r d that's available around
what we're doing around like
augmenting those that are healthy with
lenses
because i would be super interested
to sort of see what happens in these
next couple of decades
with the miniaturization towards like
the nanotech level
of the incredible computational
capacities
that we now have and then adding them to
these lenses and then getting them
implemented into
our eyes because if i can
become superhuman that way
i want to i mean it's uh
it's probably doable you know i mean i i
know
um some people that you know not quite
the
um you know irobot version um but you
know there are
uh you know i know that um you know one
of the the cornea guys actually up
at stanford uh one of his uh
projects that he's working on is a lens
you know for patients that have
you know corneal blindness you know this
issue with the front of the eye for
whatever reason
um implanting a lens that's actually
like a little tv screen
um so instead of needing to see things
from outside you wear like some glasses
um that have a camera that go to this
little tv screen that's inside of your
eye that your retina
is then just looking directly at the tv
screen you don't actually you don't even
use the cornea
it's using this little thing inside so
wow so
it's uh so people are working on it it's
you know i think it's
you know it's it's an exciting space
because ophthalmology is high
it's it's a high-tech field you know we
use
we use lasers you know we use small
instruments we use little lenses right
um so you know right so i think there's
a lot of
um there's a lot of opportunity for for
innovation in the future and
uh um i'm excited honestly to just be
beyond the start of it so
you know to see where where the field
goes as we go i'm looking forward to
the merging of that
that nanotech component with that
artificial general intelligence
computational algorithmic capacity
and then embedding that in the body
in really smart and intelligent and
light filled ways to avoid all of the
malevolent scenarios
that people paint as well in these
pictures
now is this
lens are those arms to the lens
there to make it stable in place
okay just wanted to make sure that that
was the case okay cool
all right and let's see what were
let me bring this with me what were our
or our numbers again
so three point six million
cataract procedures performed in the us
and 20 million water well okay can we
just do a little bit
of of math
because if there's 3.6
million cataract procedures
in the u.s this year i think the next
line actually does some of the math for
you
oh oh [ __ ] you're yeah wait you're right
damn good call man you're on top of this
yeah you know
they like to keep things keep things
straight forward
in the u.s there are approximately
eighteen thousand
ophthalmologists of whom nine thousand
perform surgery regularly
thus a typical surgeon might anticipate
a surgical volume of 400
ice per year whoa
so you said it takes five to 15 minutes
to specifically do the cataract one in
the modern
day and then
you might have on a day you might do
three or five of these and i mean it
fairies
i mean 10 15 in a day in a day
and a half day in a half day yeah that's
so crazy depending
on that is so nuts yeah that there's
do you have 15 15 people in a day that
are like
exposed at the eye level that you're
coming in and healing a
uh call it collagen fiber malfunction
inside of their lens well what's what's
interesting is you know you go back to
some of these older 15 unique
you have to be 15 unique combinations
of emotional intelligence and art that
has to come with that
science process yeah well and that's i
you know if you if you rewind back to
what some of the old
techniques used to be uh patients were
admitted to the hospital for three days
after cataract surgery once upon a time
right because it was big incision
there's all sorts of things that could
go wrong
um so so patients actually used to be
hospitalized after cataract surgery so
you know the way that this has been
revolutionized you know now
most surgeries are being done in surgery
centers right they're not being done in
hospitals
um so you know it's same day surgery you
come and you leave the same day
you know you're there for a couple hours
you get a little anesthesia you hang out
a little bit after make sure everything
goes okay you know family
you know goes goes and gets brunch they
come back and pick you up and uh
and you go home so it's uh you know the
the the
impact factor um is so high
you know the uh because i remember you
know
one of the first times that i was
exposed to this was maybe like second
year in med school
um you know there's this guy uh you know
we used to do these like lectures in med
school where we'd uh we
you know lunch lectures we'd have like
lectures in the morning
um and then someone come and they'd give
us a little lunch lunch lecture you get
free lunch you sit down and
i remember that i had a friend who asked
me to go to this lecture
and they were talking about a um so
there's a guy that came back from nepal
uh and his name is mike fielmeier so he
was actually you know a mentor of mine
uh and and i remember you know sitting
down for this lecture and he's talking
about how
uh you know he went to nepal um and went
to this like remote village
and uh over the course like two three
days did something like 100 cataract
surgeries
um and had the video afterwards of him
like taking the patches off all these
people
um and right it's this entire community
uh all these patients you know all these
people who
couldn't see and now they can um and you
know they're crying he's crying
everybody's crying um and i still i
still remember
why i mean like right like this is now i
mean it's not ten years
yeah coming up on right eight years ago
something like that um
and you know i still remember like
watching this
and being like wow that's that's what i
want to do
yeah that's what you know that moment
when you're like that that is
um and i went and talked to him after um
and i was like you know man i
uh i want to do what you do um and uh it
was really special because he
he totally took me in you know and i
actually went to nepal
um so he set up like a rotation for me
like i spent a month in nepal i've done
some surgery in india um so i've gotten
a chance to to get kind of uh
exposed to some of this stuff um but i
think it's you know the
the the impact factor for you know
effort
over outcome right for what you're
able to sort of uh what you're able to
do with the work
i think is it's it's it's really
powerful
that's a profound story and i'm
surprised that it didn't
come up in that first part when i talked
to you about finding that north star
because that's
so profound it's a really good example
of
of that when you provide
some a service of value to to people
especially with something as sensitive
as their eye and their vision
and you really bring it back to peak
capacity
that's that love and if it's like a
hundred
people that you in a couple days that
you heal like that
i mean that's that that sounds like
equivalent level of like you know when
the rock stars talk about filling the 50
000
seat stadium and performing well this
sounds like another level of that
in a sense yeah well and i can tell you
that you know the
the the impact also has uh
you know it's this ripple effect um you
know because
you know i have uh you know and this
happens to me you know regularly
where you know i've had you know some of
these patients where
you know let's say there's a family
member who
can't see right you know that
you know there's the international scale
of like you know
kids that can't go to school because now
they have to work
you know because their mom or their
grandma uh you know can't
take care of themselves so someone needs
to take care of them right
um and you know that some of that
happens uh you know same thing here in
the u.s
where you know you have uh uh right
this person needs a caregiver right
because you know now they're not able to
care for themselves
so you know there's this also that this
trickle-down effect
of you know patients where you know been
able to do a surgery
they have a great outcome they're able
to now take care of themselves
they get some of their own autonomy um
but then there's that
that next trickle down of you know oh
well now their kids
no longer have to take care of them
because they can take care of themselves
and the grandkids
also don't have to take care of them so
yeah so right so
you know how the freedom that that gives
to the family
right not even just the individual but
the family the kids and their unique
north star endeavors
right now they're able to to pursue what
they want to pursue
right so so that impact right like you
know what
right not even just what you were able
to do for that one person and now
you multiply that by a community
right i mean you know the the amount of
uh of change that you're able to sort of
institute with
the this relatively small uh small
change uh this one ophthalmologist
coming to nepal and healing a hundred
people in a village
of their cataracts and just like that
it's like a
massive amount of flourishing that's
unlocked it's cool yeah
it's like literally changing the world
it's beautiful yeah right
i love that story that's like such a
rich story
i love that one okay so
give us the percentage of cataracts
and then we'll do contrast that with the
percentage of your time
that's also spent on lasik and then
we'll undergo the process of explanation
of what that is so how many of the
people that you
see throughout your year what percentage
of them are for cataracts
um so i mean my current situation you
know i
um so i do all the cataract surgery for
for the practice that i'm in so
um you know the i mean
okay you know cataracts are still you
know if you look at like right like so
this year 3.6 million cataract
procedures will be performed in the
united states
um you know for a country of uh 300
million people right so
so you know it's still relatively you
know small
number of patients uh you know i get uh
one percent one percent yeah
so you know i obviously there's a you
know selection bias for
you know people that are getting sent in
to see an ophthalmologist so you know
probably a larger percentage of that
ends up being the situation for me
um but you know there's there's a lot of
other things that that go on
with uh with eyes with vision uh you
know the
uh macular degeneration diabetic
retinopathy you know as diabetes
um you know runs rampant in the u.s and
uh you know
those numbers you know continue to rise
uh diabetes as diabetes is uncontrolled
people
develop changes new blood vessel growth
inside the eyes diabetic retinopathy
uh macular degeneration as we live
longer uh you know we know that
macular degeneration is an age-related
change tends to run in families
uh so you know as some of these issues
that start
um you know as life expectancy has gone
up there
these are these are later in life uh
conditions
you know it but but i would actually say
that a lot of
you know the the joy that i get out of
my work
is that you know the nature of a lot of
these problems happening later in life
is that a lot of these patients you know
are people that are relatively healthy
otherwise
you know right so so you know you have
yeah that's
that's a good thing yeah as long as it's
just that one thing yeah
yeah so usually there's a lot more like
you're describing with
there's likely some stuff happening with
diabetes or
hypertension or potentially
the early formations of cancer cells
there's all different types of
of it's a whole synthesis symbiosis
in the in the body and so it's almost
like maybe if you heal
the the lens in this case
it could create some other downstream
effects not only in the community but
also in the body yeah
of health yeah and now you know as
you're able to see now you know like
right like
what do we do for for diabetes at least
kind of
first line stuff diet and exercise right
so
you know you you need to be able to see
to do those things
yeah right so you know there's there's
so much
of you know self-care um taking care of
you know
watching your diet being able to have
access to a good diet a lot of these
things
you know they they're all very they're
they're intricately
intricately tied yeah then
so cataracts is probably more than lasik
for you
right now at the moment so i'm trained
in lasik but um
you know most most of what i'm doing
right now is cataract surgery
okay now
let's unpack let's do stats and then
we'll do
uh on lasik and then we'll do the we'll
walk you guys through a graphic that we
have for you
so oh
one moment i need to
do a small little scheme converter
reset there we go now you'll see the
you see this nice and highlighted okay
so 10 million americans
have had lasik surgery since it was
first approved by the fda
in 1999 around
700 000 lasik surgeries are done
each year which is down from a peak of
1.4 million in
2000 so
700 000 lasik surgeries done each year
and the number was 3.6 million cataracts
done each year okay so now
lasik is named after a pioneer
of the field is it
oh i thought it was no if i'm i thought
one
is it not not that i know oh i thought
it was
i totally thought it was named after a
um a pioneer in the field
you thought it was like a guy was dr
lasik well
well especially because uh
well let's see because
lasik the eye surgery to correct vision
in which a laser reshapes the inner
cornea oh
a 1990s acronym
from laser assisted in situ
keratomilusis keratomilius
inside you yeah but who's inside you
yeah
interesting i didn't i thought that
there was
so in terms of founding a pioneer
there was it was it a team
um that's actually a good question you
know the the fir
you know i know that um you know there
are
you know when i'm not sure who they
totally
credit with starting lasik
um you know i i know that there there
was a
a handful of uh of guys at
mass eye and ear um who i know were were
kind of playing with the laser before
you know back before the fda i had to
prove things
um but we'd we'd probably have to double
check who
who the official the official record
okay um
who the official record they uh
and then
now let's pull up the
the visual explanation
of what is going on and have you
unpack for us so the
so if we run through a uh
our our little visual here which which i
think
does a nice job of illustrating kind of
the different parts
so there's actually two lasers that are
used
um so there's a what was called a
femtosecond laser
which is what's responsible for creating
this flap
and then there's an eczema laser which
actually does
the research resurfacing on the cornea
so if we
look at so if we think about our cornea
essentially the two parts of the
procedure are creating the flap
so if we look at kind of image number
two here
you know that's the flap creation so you
have one laser that's responsible for
doing that
it kind of breaks up all these like
little cells and you actually go we go
in manually and lift the flap
so this is the this is the 500 micron
550 micron
so 550 micron cornea probably average
flap size
is like 110 microns that's probably so
so it only
gets from the very like one-fifth of the
size of it
yeah so we're resurfacing that 150
microns so
so we're taking it lifting up that 110
micron flap
and then the eczema laser is going to be
the one that
that's that purple or i'm sorry the
green laser that we have there at number
three
where it's resurfacing that center of
the cornea so
resurfacing yeah so it basically is
it is kind of be it's almost like a
beating down of
these cells to reshape how this cornea
is going to look so
you know if we if we have a cornea
that's sitting something like this
and we flatten it yeah yeah now it
doesn't have
as much refractive power yeah yeah as it
doesn't have as much refractive power
those light rays
that are landing on on the retina now
we're going to sit a little
we're going to land a little bit further
back so that's how we treat myopia
so if you're nearsighted we actually
flatten the cornea
versus hyperopia so farsightedness
that those light rays are landing behind
the retina so we want to bring them up
so we actually need more power so the
resurfacing is on the outside portion of
the cornea so it actually has
kind of this sort of effect and it's
increasing the power
is it a similar laser that same laser
that can do the hyperopia or the myopia
effect it's just a matter of
where it's doing the treatment right so
if it's doing the treatment in the
middle
it'll ablate and it'll flatten that down
if it's doing it
on the outside it'll belate there and
that kind of gives you
fascinating so if
on that story i told you earlier where
my
farsighted vision is deteriorating
would that then be a hyperopia myopia
okay right so oh so i am nearsighted
most people are nearsighted but but then
my farsightedness
is bad which means i have myopia but
then
if i'm good farsighted but i suck
nearsighted which you were describing
with like your father or just aging
parents in general
they would be hyperopic and then
then if that is usually corrected today
in the most cost effective solution with
the
glasses to just put on and then just to
like
look at your smartphone or whatever or
a document close to you there's one more
wrinkle
the uh so so the so the the the effect
that happens with age this
um you know this 40 plus change is
presbyopia
oh yeah presbyopia right there's
um so so our myopia right
is so the name is it kind of says what
you have
yeah so if you're nearsighted that means
you can see things up close
right i'm nearsighted so then by
definition if i'm nearsighted
i can't see things far away yeah yeah
right so so this is my myopia
hyperopia is i'm farsighted so now i can
see
the far away yeah but then i can't see
the things up close
which is usually the older people
neither
yeah so most people are are myopic so
most people
are are near sighted yeah okay the the
aging population change presbyopia is
actually
the accommodation that starts to go away
so let's say
so that that's the ability for me to
look far away
and things to be in focus and then look
at my watch and things to do
so i'm already getting presbyopia
in the sense of yeah so probably what's
happening with that far
cited deterioration that i'm
experiencing yeah yeah so
probably what's happening is is becoming
more
myopic i'm becoming more myopic given my
screen use
probably yeah exactly yeah so actually
planetarily we are collectively becoming
more myopic given our screen use
and that's well documented and that's
well documented so almost
certainly people's far-sighted abilities
are deteriorating extremely rapidly due
to
excessive phone and computer use
that's fascinating and then one more
time so press biopia is the
muscle so it's the loss of accommodation
loss of accommodation yeah i love that
word okay accommodation
and and the loss of accommodation is
actually thought to be
not because of the muscle because but
from a change in the lens where it loses
its elasticity it loses elasticity
so if you think about this muscle that
you know constricts
and this lens that's supposed to swell
up
to give you more refractive power yeah
as we start as it doesn't swell up as
much
accommodation right then you lose that
in your sightedness
i see i see i see so the accommodation
deterioration
is another way to potentially reference
part of the
myopia because i i can't
my my lens itself i can't access the
same capacities in that lens to see
far away not quite
okay okay yeah i'm all trying
yeah yeah all right so so if we think
about
it's switching it's switching between
something that's close and something
that's far
so so if i gave you
some glasses right that were maybe
you know if i because you wear glasses
or contacts now no
nothing yeah well i have worn
occasionally switching between
wearing glasses just to be able to try
and like
mess around with seeing things far away
more easily but it almost
that whole aspect of
vision correction like that it almost
there's something so like it takes away
from the normal
biological process in the sense of when
you put on glass
to see something far away and you
wear those glasses for two hours and you
take them off
your normal vision itself
feels in a strange sense worse
and so that was something that was very
off-putting
in that process i assume that that's
something that happens
yeah you kind of get used to the the new
refractive change right
so you know if i had to guess you know
you're probably
like a minus 150 or a minus two
something like that
where you know you have things that a
distance are kind of fuzzy but they're
not
bad enough to where it ends up you know
really hurting and driving and
impacting your life too much um but you
know the reason
why your accommodation is still intact
is that if you have those glasses on
right and you you're now
set up sort of for distance uh and then
you look
at your watch you can still read it
that's the accommodation okay i'm i'm
following now cool
okay okay and then
the procedure for correction
in lasik is
in step two is a different laser takes
that little
hundred micron small flap of the cornea
and then a second laser comes in
to do either correction of
of myopia or
or hyperopia which plus minus
astigmatism
oh and astigmatism so we can correct
astigmatism as well
okay and then so so lasik is is mostly
for
either correcting myopia hyperopia or
stigmatism
that that's that's that's it okay it's
interesting so now
but and then you put the flap back down
and then yeah and so then you see here
so you see how like if you compare step
two
to step four you see how it's kind of
flatter
oh right oh i see oh it literally
flattens the that is that flattening the
cornea itself
so this would be like a myopic
correction right so you see how
how the center of it is flatter
yeah yeah right so so we resurfaced the
cornea
it made it flatter and then we go to
five where we put the flap back down
um that's what i really like about this
diagram is that you know this savvy is
obviously
exaggerated you know the flattening
aspect is not
it's not that flat right that
is like you know you can put your coffee
someone like looks at you
on this side right here
so it would bulge outward more if you um
were doing hyper opia uh
theoretically you know that most of the
flattening change is in the periphery
oh okay yeah instead of smack dab there
in the center
so it's fascinating right and i think
you know if you think about
you know the first guys that thought
hey why don't we laser why don't we
laser this cornea
um you know yeah it's beautiful and i
remember you know even when i had
um what were you getting corrected so i
was about a minus three
so i was myopic so i was probably a
little more near-sighted than you
yeah you know to where i needed to wear
glasses full-time i couldn't drive
without classes
oh you couldn't even drive without
glasses yeah i had them on all the time
oh
okay and then and now now how does lasik
though when you get that procedure
to correct you from minus three
to zero to zero when that's happening
how does that not affect your
nearsightedness so you're trying to
correct
your farsightedness but not affect your
nearsightedness because i still have
accommodation
so the economy so the
if you still have accommodation which
pretty much everybody does
up until 40 or so so i is so
once i hit you know 45 or so
which is actually kind of one of the
considerations you know when you look
at doing lasik for someone who's 40 you
know sometimes we have patients who come
in who are 40 they're 45
you know and they want to get out of the
reading glasses you know so
that that's where the interplay of
accommodation
starts to come in and you know yeah and
i i know some of my mentors
um you know were have referred to to
accommodation sort of as like the holy
grail of ophthalmology
sounds like it right in the sense that
you know the
to have that ability to see things far
away
and then see things up close so that's
what multifocal lenses kind of hit
right but that's super human i love that
right yeah
but they're not um you know multifocal
lenses aren't perfect
um so you know the the the ability to
really
get you know that distance vision that
18 year old eyes yeah get those 18 year
old eyes back yeah
um you know the technology gets a little
bit closer every year
um but we're still growing you know
there's still room to grow
and now when you get lasik how long
does lasik take and
how much does it approximately cost
and are you put under anesthesia
so the
uh so lasik takes um you know maybe 15
minutes 20 minutes something like that
similar very quick crazy um you know
the uh as far as the cost you know are
you under
are you under anesthesia so i know some
people that do it with nothing with
nothing um
i know some that do it um so it's all
you know
usually for lasik there's not anybody
from anesthesia present you know it ends
up being
um kind of as like a procedure so
sometimes you give
a little bit of like a sleepy pill where
you know you're
uh yeah something like a valium or
something like that where you know
you're a little awake you're a little
you know you
but you're relaxed and it's mostly kind
of anti-anxiety
procedure itself is pretty comfortable
you know like it's uh you know there's a
couple parts where
maybe you feel a little suction maybe
you feel a little pressure
um and uh but
but for the most part you know it's not
something that's too big of a deal from
a comfort standpoint
um and uh for as far as cost goes you
know
things kind of vary region part of the
country um
it usually ends up being a couple
thousand bucks a night yeah
yeah i'm really really fascinated with
the
addition and augmentation of
our eyes given our technological
capacities as a species
so all lasik
does not touch the lens is that right
correct
all lasik is cornea awkward cool
interesting did you think you were going
to learn so much about eyes today
bro yeah that's the whole point of the
show on up the ball
just the whole freaking point that
my mind's going to be continuously blown
our audience reminds me
actually the first time that we hung out
i told you how fascinating it was that
andrew huberman was actually the one
that taught me
that the eyes are the are part of the
nervous system are you talking about
they're the only part of the nervous
system that just protrudes
out and like touches the environment the
brain it's the brain protruding central
nervous system yeah it's so fascinating
yeah see i i adore this type of stuff
and
and it's such a cool way to like augment
this central nervous system
the brain from something that we can
just
from the exterior just like right here
that's right there yeah i love that
and eyes are also fascinating because
they're the quote like gateways to the
soul
and so then there's that aspect to it as
well that's a whole other layer
that's a romantic layer that's though
yeah that's that layer so
yeah i have so many other interesting
questions
about this that i'll try and i'll try
and power
try and power through them
here um
is there a are you aware
of any sort of reasons for
the differences in the colorations of
the irises across the planet
or is that a biological
expression of the genomes of the
different
areas yeah that's probably the best way
i could describe it okay
it's just the thing yeah okay
yeah you know there there's been some
work uh internationally
on uh surgically changing iris colors
um you know they and and actual like
little implants
um you know the the current uh
at least for us fd for fda approved
stuff in the states
um you know there there is a uh there is
a company that does make an artificial
iris um
but it's not for cosmetic purposes you
know
if you had trauma you've got like major
issue kind of with the eyes some
patients are actually born without an
iris
um so you can get all kinds of glare
all sorts of issues kind of as a result
of that so you know there
there are some you know really good
medical reasons to
consider doing something like that um
you know i
i've had to unfortunately uh manage some
patients that have had
you know artificial irises implanted
internationally
um that have come back with all sorts of
problems with their eyes
um so you know yeah i would say that you
know where the technology is at the
moment
um i uh i wouldn't i wouldn't go down
that road
have you
explored that limbo ring that's outside
of the
iris donald hoffman
had a bunch of interesting research that
he was
reciting in the case against reality his
recent book where he talked about
the the
limbo rings relationship with
biological mate selection
so we we
identify we're in the bounce wow
category now
that um we we identify
that humans
with larger thicker limbal rings
are perceived as healthier biologically
as
mates which i thought was very
interesting
yeah i i would say we're dabbling out of
my uh
my expertise the limbo rings and and
then there's the whole
field of richard dawkins calls us the
extended phenotype which is like the way
that we
portray ourselves in the internet sphere
and so it's fascinating because people
will
take of course we are familiar with the
phenomenons of people that take their
photos and then into
photoshop or any editing software that
then i mean we live in los angeles
nobody does that blemishes
isn't that interesting you can increase
the limbal ring
thickness and then become more
attractive that way so there's
all these sort of hacks that
can be leveraged in this extended
phenotype
era that we're now the instagram game
yeah bro that upping that's
actually that's [ __ ] nuts like dude
upping the quote
you know graham or the extended
phenotype in general
is super closely related to mate
selection now which is insanely
fascinating
um okay so we got
through a bunch of that um
yeah we got through a lot of the good
stuff that i wanted to get through
um
one of the things that is
we've been touching on this kind of
throughout but it's like
something that's really near and dear to
my heart
in many ways is the
sort of like that
fresh like
not only the fresh 450 ophthalmologists
in the united states that come into the
scene
every year but even you know at a
youthful
space at you know age 18 or whenever
the young person's getting interested in
when they have that profound moment like
what you shared
that i would love to sort of see
a the healthcare industrial complex
has a lot of perverse incentives
especially in the pharmaceutical
industry
and especially in the insurance game
and approximately 20 of the usa gdp is
tied up in health care
and it's kind of crazy that the
idea of a
a physician that is not funneled
immediately into kaiser
to earn three or four hundred thousand
dollars a year to pay off their
student loans can potentially take on a
bigger risk
i love this idea take on an a bigger
risk after already taking on
a good amount of risk and
become like create more physician
entrepreneurship even from that age of
18 onward
there there's both the sort of niceness
to the systematization of the
healthcare industry where you can ensure
that
there's like an mcat that has to be
passed and there's a series of these
tests and there's a
and there's a lot of other processes
with residencies
and they sort of ensure that
the physician is a general level of
basic
competency which is great at the same
time i love the idea of
balancing that out with pursuing
what it would be like for instead of the
physician to enter into
that mainstream like verti vertically
integrated
uh kaiser system who's now starting to
get into education which is kind of
yeah which is kind of interesting taking
the full stack
it would be interesting to see if
that more entrepreneur you you listen to
this earlier the more entrepreneurial
the more
tech the more sort of silicon
valley-esque aspects
to the in healthcare industrial complex
can potentially
eradicate some of the perverse
incentives and
you know drain that dirty bath water but
keep the golden baby
um and sort of add in that
youthful homeostatic capacity retention
perspective
uh rather than treating only the
pathologies
how do you see that sort of forming in
the next
couple of decades
yeah i mean you know i think the
there's a couple roads
that you can walk right and there's a
couple different paths and i think
you know as as things change you know
the viability
of each of those paths um you know if
it is is probably different in 2020
2021 um than it was 10 years ago 20
years ago 30 years ago
um you know and you know as as things
begin to shift
you know it's it's hard um you know it's
hard to have a crystal ball to know
where it goes
but you know i can tell you that if if
we kind of group these
into a couple main camps
right a couple of main camps and i think
this is this is not just uh
ophthalmology but you know
medicine in general that you know you
you finish up with training
and you can pursue the the academic
route right you know you
get a job with big university um and you
know you pursue
the the academic road um you know if you
don't pursue the academic road there's
some of these big
health care systems that you've already
sort of touched on there's
you know california there's kaiser
there's a number of these you know these
big uh kind of private
health care systems that exist around
the country um
and then there's you know door number
three which is
uh you know the the true kind of private
practice and you know there's some
you know big group private practices
that are you know a bunch of a
particular specialist
um that you know all of these uh
you know members within the group or
stakeholders and you know our owners
in this group and then there's you know
the the smaller
scale uh even single provider right
single provider with their own private
practice
um right and and i think if you you
break up
those three big different camps i love
this
you know i i think that you'll find you
know people
that are probably a good fit for each
one
right you know and and i think that you
know as we
because i i think it it's funny as as i
get older i find myself
you know thinking you know more less in
terms of good and bad
less in terms of right and wrong um but
more in terms of fit
right and you know i think you know we
we have our preferences we have our
tendencies we know
you know where where we're comfortable
and where we feel
like we're best utilized and i think
that you know my hope uh
for for myself and you know all of uh
you know the the budding physicians
coming out of training
um is just to know that and to kind of
have that courage to pursue
you know which one is right for you and
right for your situation
um right because there's a different we
all have a different appetite
for risk you know we all have a
different uh desire to
you know create versus be a part of
something
um you know and and after going through
all this medical training and you know
meeting
you know a lot of my friends or
physicians some of them in ophthalmology
some of them
in other fields and i can tell you that
i think you know if you end up in the
wrong one of those baskets
um you know you you probably become very
frustrated with
with your career with the trajectory
with how things went
um because the the rules of engagement
um are different you know the rules of
engagement
and you know what you're able to do how
you're able um
to to facilitate things for yourself and
for your patients and what you're able
to do
um you know there's uh all in all of
these different spheres
i think it's it's it's a different um
it's a different playing field
um so you know i think the main the big
important thing for
for the young physician i think is is to
have some of that
uh you know self-reflection on you know
where
where am i best suited right you know
where where does my skill set
lie um and uh you know we kind of
touched on a conversation earlier with
uh
with ray dalio and some of this you know
what uh whitney talks about with
bridgewater of
you know personality characteristics and
tendencies
of you know where can we take somebody
and and i you know ideally fit them in a
situation to where they're kind of
efficient water right because then
you're going to get maximum output
and you know particularly right happy
physicians lead to happy patients lead
to good outcomes
you know well documented that you know
burnout and
uh you know you know physician stress
all of these things lead to
medical errors they lead to uh you know
higher cost of
higher health care costs there's all
sorts of issues from um
and i think that some of that probably
stems from being
being in the wrong basket right you know
not really being a
you know kind of true and authentic to
where
where you belong um so you know i think
as
the as medicine you know undoubtedly is
is changing and you know you've alluded
to uh you know
the the insurance game has changed and
you know what the
uh the terms are uh are are different
now than they were
um you know a lot of the the people that
that trained me and a lot of you know
the older physicians that that
as i went through medical training um
you know often remind
remind us that you know the the medical
record system
is different and yeah ehr is different
and you know the check boxes are
different and you know what
um what what things are uh i have
changed over the years but
you know i think we are where we are
right
you know where we are where we are you
can't just scrap it right and start over
um
so you know i think that as i
you know reflecting kind of on my own
goals you know as i'm just trying to
structure
where i fit in this system and where i
think you know my skills are best suited
uh for my patients but also
you know my popular my uh my community
and kind of the the population
whole of where how can you really
maximize your own output um that that's
been a lot of my focus
on you know how how i structure my
career moving forward
yeah i like how you focus on the word
fit and then i also like how you
highlight all of the different options
on the buffet you have to know
the options on the buffet and then you
have to know where you fit
given like dalio talks about that
psychometric analysis that helps you
understand that at a deeper level as
well
spot on and
to be inspired to drain the dirty bath
water of the perverse incentives and to
step up and as an entrepreneur physician
to come in
and to architect the more prosperous
more well-being oriented medical
infrastructures
that's a whole big challenge that people
have to be willing to
be inspired and motivated and have the
right incentives to step into and that's
a big part of
my ethos and the show is to make sure
that we have that
in place for the future
then another sort of aspect that came up
was the synthesis of the east and west
which had a lot to do with the modules
that we were talking about sort of those
future modules in the physician process
because
west should have east modules
around holistic wellness
and natural sort of modalities of
of healing a lot of the current western
infrastructure is now starting to
prescribe
meditation and mindfulness and sort of
like you and indicated earlier the diet
and nutrition being so fundamental sleep
being so fundamental
but yeah to be sovereign with your
awareness
your consciousness that very first
principle that we were talking about
when you create that pause so that
you're not
reactive but that rather you
can slow down and like a jedi like a
ninja
with high emotional intelligence
navigate the world
of people's psyches it creates
a massive decrease in cortisol a massive
increase in peace and joy that you sort
of butterfly effect out around you
and so the east in itself can also
learn some of the western principles and
so
ultimately a synthesis is going to be
what
is called for and i think that's that's
uh
that's what the greatest minds are is is
they're like that and they see that
from what i understand
you know yeah what i've been meaning to
tell you yes sir
is uh you know it's
i i find it fascinating how
because i've watched some of some of
your other work um
and and your your ability to
swim in the deep end so to say
um with with people that do something
day in and day out right um is
uh it's it's actually it's kind of
fascinating
and uh and i really i you know i enjoy
it and i still remember even from the
the first time that we met
um thinking you know that guy
doesn't know he's not an ophthalmologist
you know but uh but but i think that you
know the level
the high level of conversation that
we're able to have
on a topic that you know i had to go to
school for for a long time to be able to
to to conversate on um and uh you know
the depth at which you're able to sort
of swim at the same topic not just with
me but you know i know with a lot of the
other
the individuals that you've interviewed
um it's
uh it's special and special it really is
i'm ridiculously grateful for
you recognizing me and that ability
and for mentioning that that was
very makes me feel very warm makes me
feel very recognized
very loved and appreciated i'm glad i
mean it's earned thank you concerned
because these things don't come they
don't come free you know yeah these
things don't come from they
it took uh like 2
000 like 14
to maybe 2 000 and like 16
17 maybe like something like that of
like really hardcore plymouthy in the
sciences specifically like obsessive
compulsive polymothy in the sciences
to especially the explain like i'm five
like the sort of carl sagan neil
degrasse tyson style of science
communication
of
understanding those like fundamental
units
of science across the different
disciplines
like in biology it being the cell but
then also in neuroscience
the neuron and then
the even the the
the periodic table and and especially in
physics
sort of understanding the scales of all
the way from astrophysics
all the way down to the quantum
mechanics and sort of rather than that
bohr model
seeing it more like an electron cloud
which is so fascinating right there's
all these sort of
um these different
ways of understanding at
and explain like i'm five child level
scales and the material physical
world that if we do a better job
at immersing kids into the virtual
pedagogy of these sciences they can
really become
autodidacts and the information
technology thank goodness
for being able to maybe jump on the you
know kirk's gaza
in a nutshell which is a really good
channel that animates a lot of these
more cutting edge scientific
and that but that's what enables me the
fact that i i took all that in
it gives me the ability to now be able
to swim in the deeper waters and the
depths like
for example we have a lot of people that
come on the program that talk about
blockchain and cryptocurrency and
decentralization
and so to be able to sort of navigate
what the space of cryptography and
mathematics around that look like is
similar in the sense of being able to
navigate that depth
but then also to swim at it from a
polymathic
breadth as well and that's usually when
the connections between the profound
ideas comes
but in this case it's really just like
being a kid is so important
and like knowing how to ask good
questions about the process like
being a kid like knowing that like i
want to
google gaga for two hours straight
about ophthalmology like i want to know
the ins and outs
of how to heal cataracts i want to know
the ins and outs of
healing the myopia hyperopia
and astigmatism that occurs with lasik
like i want to know
i want to know it and i want to be aware
of it
because i know that sometimes it's even
a simple
and i know other people do as well but
sometimes it's that simple knowing
of that component to our physical
reality that
makes it
makes you able to butterfly effect out
that
knowledge that you've integrated to
other people
that may not even know that it exists
and so some people may not know that
these
solutions to existing
diseases that are developing with eyes
exist
and corrections even for augmentations
for people that
don't call it necessarily a disease but
now lasik exists
for corrections that make people feel
really i mean you can probably say like
after
going from negative three to zero like
you probably felt like a god
um i mean it's to to wake up in the
morning
and just go and you wake up in the
morning and
uh you know i can tell you i i still uh
my old scratched up glasses are like
sitting in my living room
um and i remember you know seeing
trying to you know run around with these
these glasses and you get like
you know you see all these like little
like scratches and things and
uh you know you put contacts in you put
them in take them out
but lost my contact solution i went on a
trip i
i forgot my buy forgot the contact box
um you know
there's like so many of these like
little nuisances
um that are just gone you know now you
just wake up and go
um it's uh it it's actually it's kind of
crazy
how um you know the the adaptation
you know when when you look at you know
how humans adapt
uh it almost feels like i've always been
like this
you know wow so there's something to
think about right
yeah you know my entire life i was in
glasses
uh up until you know five months ago
five six months ago that's when it
happened that's when you're releasing it
yeah about five six months ago and if
you ask me now
it almost feels like i've always been
like this always
that's so so fascinating and yeah we all
know that
stereotypical archetype of the person
that's carrying around their
their contact lenses and solution
and carrying case and like all that oh
can you imagine like a chimp that's you
know having a yeah carry that around
like in the back like versus just yeah
now like you described it's just such a
beautiful wake up go like ready to go
i love it and also it makes you a better
it makes you better at navigating
maybe sudden events as well because when
you're maybe at
so minus three was lack of
far sighted ability so i was so my
reading if i held something like maybe
right here
that that was about where i needed it to
be to
to be able to read if it was like here i
couldn't make it up
it's like oh it was that bad yeah well
that's really
i was like right here i mean we i mean i
treat some patients that are like they
can read things that they're like right
here
um so oh that's really bad so is that
like minus five or something yeah even
more i mean like you know you get
so crazy man minus goes to a bunch you
know you get patients that are like
high high myopia like minus 20 that's
the thing
what's some what's the rating scale
called the optometrian rating scale
what's that called
oh like this like uh the minus plus
thing yeah um
that's a good question i uh i mean they
basically they just number
uh the lenses so so basically the way
the numbering works
it's with the so it all goes back to
optics
and so if you so like a uh a minus
one um or like you know this one die
like the definite like this is so the
larger question is like right like what
is a diopter
so that's actually what these um these
numbers are so minus one
diopters plus one diopter um so a
diopter
is how uh so it's numbered by how much
you can move a beam of light at one
one meter so right so one diopter
can move a beam of light one centimeter
at one meter
and then two diopters is two centimeters
at one meter and three diopters is three
centimeters at one meter
so so it so that so it's actually that
that's the measurement
of the mathematical sort of optics uh
equivalent of what those diopters are
doing
so that's why as the number goes up it
has more power
this is also sort of the process that
is one undergoes as a
patient when they walk in for all of
their eye needs is that they go through
a
usually an optometrist first
it's usually what you see so there's a
bunch uh
so if you look at like eye care
providers in the united states
uh there's about it's somewhere eight
nine
ten to one or so optometrist
ophthalmologist just by practicing
providers in the country
um so you know if there's like fifteen
thousand optomet or fifteen twenty
thousand now i think
it said uh ophthalmologists yeah it's
eighteen
something yes the uh depending on which
ones are practicing and you know there's
like a lot of
we'll call it a range you know medicine
loves rain medicine loves rain 200
000 no i think it's like 120 000
something like that oh
oh okay that's still a lot yeah so the
um yeah medicine loves ranges and
you know it's funny that a lot of the
the terminology
you know i you know i incorporated into
just you know
the way that i talk now you know right
yeah yeah
it's funny your profession as it it
molds into
your personal life and how you converse
with people and uh you know my family
reminds me on kind of a regular basis
that
you know i i start uh speaking in in
vegatis
you know like uh you know yeah the
ranges yeah yeah they're
the ra you know you uh it's uh you know
it's funny from uh like a cultural
standpoint but um
you know so if you so just you know uh
eye care providers nationwide right you
know just by
by sheer number you know if in actuality
right if you were to ask uh you know the
average person what's the difference
between an optometrist ophthalmologist
um you know i i'm not sure what they
would tell you but uh
we should know by now that so the
optometrist is usually the one that
conducts the
the basic more basic eye examinations
themselves
and then also then makes the diagnostics
of what potentially some of the
developing
pathologies are and then the
ophthalmologist
is the one that is practiced in the
surgical
procedures that then enable the
correction of set pathologies
yes generally speaking is that about
yeah i mean so there's two
the two kind of main routes where you
know optometrists are doing
diagnosis of disease they're doing
treatment of some diseases
um you know the the route is through
optometry school
um and uh prescription glasses uh a lot
of that stuff is done
by optometrists whereas ophthalmologists
are actual medical doctors right so
so they're md's that went through med
school um and then
kind of residency fellowship in some
sort of field in ophthalmology so
um you know depending on the state
you know there uh there are some uptime
you know some states
they where they draw the line of you
know who does what
uh and you know every state has like a
little bit of a different rule on some
of that but
but for the most part you know
ophthalmologists are
you know they're they're surgeons
they're doing uh
you know adv kind of more advanced
procedures where you're using lasers
you're doing injections and
eyes your um you know surgical
management of things you're suturing
things you're cutting things
you know those are those things are all
done by ophthalmologists
yeah and that sort of enables the
ophthalmologist to see
like you were indicating a good amount
of the
patients in those you know five to 15
minute
cataract correction procedures being
able to get through 15 of those
in a day has a lot to do with uh
with the strong team around you that
enables
that flow to happen well you know it's
important because
you know the the when you look at
healthcare
you know as a system right you know not
every problem is a surgical problem
right
so you know in in a perfect system
you know if you had a surgical problem
you would go see a surgeon if you had a
medical problem you would see
someone who treats the medical problem
if you needed you know if we're sticking
with the
you know the ophthalmology or the the
kind of eye care um
modality you know there there are all
these different kind of players and even
within that they're they're
sub-specialists right there's
there there's corneal specialists
there's retina specialists
um there's oculoplastic specialists
right so
so but you know patients don't
necessarily come
in you know with a sign that says you
know i have a retina problem
yeah you know refer me to a retina
specialist right yeah so
so the the system as a whole kind of
needs
a team in place um in the same way
if you were to relate this to kind of
general medicine you know
they're your their their primary care
providers and then there's cardiologists
and then there's gi specialists
you know so so in order for the system
to kind of function as a whole you know
you want your cardiologist taking care
of your heart
but you know i don't know if you want to
ask your cardiologist about the best way
to deal with your back pain
yeah right you know you're there you
know maybe there's another doctor that
would be better suited for that
um so as we i think that in the team
sort of approach you know shuffling
patients through
to get to the right provider for you
know match the provider to the problem
uh i think that's that's kind of wha
what we're all trying to accomplish
yeah yeah i love the idea of a suite
of both specialists and generalists that
sort of
not only assist in the optimal
health and well-being of each person but
also in the health and well-being and
prosperity of the planet
itself so that's going to be an
important fusion that we have in our
future
it already is in many ways like the
departments
in the united states are kind of like
that in their own specialist regards
and then they're sort of that more
generalist
uh executive functioning
as well which kind of is a little bit in
a sense it's kind of
prefrontal also which is kind of funny
like
there's a many components
of brain functionality and then there's
sort of the executive functioning of the
pfc
and
yeah oh uh i have
two three i have three we'll get through
these
um they're exciting they're exciting
ones to to go through
the first one is
the avid sailing and surfing
which is dope yeah i love it it's like
in the bio is
is like dr alex nesivic is an
ophthalmologist
and avid sir sailor and surfer
that's like and that's it that's all you
need to write there
and that's like that's great so okay so
like let's if
those are the only other two things
um no you know i i think the um
you know what what's you know to circle
back to
the the flow pull up some of these right
awesome pictures right if we pull it if
we go to the the
the flow concept um you know some haley
you know actually talks about uh
sailing being a high sort of flow
activity
right where it's something that requires
a lot
of uh right it requires training
requires
a a certain skill set to be acquired
that's right um and then it requires you
know
for kind of rigid rules on how you
execute on this
skill set to achieve your goal um and
you know i think that
that sailing is able to kind of channel
you know
such a kind of primal almost
kind of man versus wild thing you know
like if you go back to you know the the
christopher columbus days right of
you know this your opportunity to
challenge you know your yourself and
your vessel
um and you know kind of what what man
was able to create and to build um
and to use that to challenge nature
uh to move to move forward to navigate
these waters
uh yeah right i love that that's great
yeah yeah yeah
that that's i think that's you know
there's a lot of joy that i get out of
it um but that's
uh you know i think there's a lot of
parallels between
uh between sailing between surfing
between surgery
um you know and i think uh you know
anybody who who kind of
uh uh pursued has interest in some of
these pursuits i think
would be able to uh uh kind of testify
to some of that
yeah i love how you circle it back to
flow yeah for sure
and those are the ocean is is really
one of the biggest gifts of california
and in many ways and the ocean is
also a cornerstone in our biological
evolution and water
is so fundamental also to life here and
i adore the relationship that we strike
with the ocean and surfing and sailing
and i like how i love how you tied that
to flow
then good good okay i wanted one i
wanted
to i could tell when like you've got an
idea that you like
yeah and you get like this like little
but you haven't said it yet you know you
can
see the uh the the the expression on
your face before it even lands it's like
this is good i i know this is a good one
like this is gonna be a good one
yeah yeah that's cute i like that i like
that a lot yeah
i like how you're beginning to draw
these
like interviewer nuances they're so
funny i love i love
i love how you're doing that well it's
it's a little bit of medicine you know
because you study people
exactly right yeah so also you're you're
acting as a
as a mirror to the things that i
normally don't get to self-reflect on
that much and that's really important
and really insightful
that's usually what i do as the
interviewers i mirror for the guests
to unpack their flower their essence
um the interviewer becomes the
interviewee
yeah which has happened a couple times
guests have
asked to interview me afterward and then
we've done that and that's been that's
been really insightful
so yeah actually
could be interesting as we talk media
strategy for
um this is the link is in the bio to
alex's instagram aka dr k
so it's harder for people to say
knissovic
so you just go by dr k to most of the
patients
so it was a little bit of a joke you
know i've got um you know a lot of
patients that come in
uh you know i i usually start things uh
you know you introduce yourself uh
as as you should you know hello my name
is dr kanezovic
um and i get a fair amount of doctor
what um and i'm like yo people call me
dr k
for short um so the uh so i ended up
stealing that for the instagram handle i
thought it would be a funny little play
and then that's in the
the bio go and give him a follow he's
got great posts and stories and then
we also have the youtube channel
for alex as well he has a couple great
interviews up on there
that i highly recommend watching if you
guys
are interested in continuing the
exploration of the subjects
that he's been teaching us about and
he's also got a good kind of trailer
video
over there on the far right that is
really solid
and that is sort of a good
as we're talking about you know
interviewing the interviewer it could be
interesting to
potentially see your content strategy
unfold in the space like there's really
there's not that many people that know
how to teach really well
in science communication especially
about complex concepts like
ophthalmology
and also have the emotional intelligence
to basically bring on
other doctors and their specialties and
interview them and stuff like that so
there's a really great fit potentially
for you in the media space which i'm
really looking forward to
seeing you blossom in it's gonna be it's
gonna be super exciting really excited
for that
i i appreciate it you know i i think
it's um
but i think i think it's important to
follow and and we talk about this about
following your passions
um you know and and i think that we are
we're multi-dimensional
right nobody's just one thing um so you
know i think it's important as you
as you identify things that that
resonate for you
um you know as you you're able to
identify things that you're passionate
about things that you care about
you know that that you have the the
courage to
to move on some of those and uh you know
i think that
as uh as physicians you know we get a
lot of training
on the job um and while the job is
important and i think that
you know most physicians that go through
training probably stick with
clinical medicine you know there's a lot
of other ways that you can
become involved in your community you
can make your contribution uh
kind of the population as uh as a whole
and whether that is you know however
that may fit you know be that fit for
you whether it's
in research whether it's in you know new
drug development
new surgical technique development uh
new device development
um or in in the media space where you
know i think that
you know physician involvement in media
uh is
you know what used to be uh you know i
mean i think even a couple years ago
um you know was a little bit of a faux
pas right you know you didn't really see
doctors
uh on on tick tock uh and you know now
you have
you know there's these you know doctors
dancing around
on tick-tock which is great it's
humanizing as well which is great
yeah i think it's i think it's important
you know because it
um you know people
i think sometimes you know forget that
uh
you're behind the white code and behind
you know all this stuff
um you know they're the doctors are
people just like you you know yeah
um yeah you almost want a doctor that
knows how to ebb and flow between the
seriousness and the play because that's
what gives
your insight into their ability to go
off
scientific procedure into that art
territory
and emotional intelligence as needed
yeah
and i think that you know is uh is
extremely important to be able to kind
of meet people
where they're at right and uh and and i
think that
you know as you you pursue um
you know your your unique ability right
your unique
uh sort of ethos of how you want to
you know play out this thing uh you know
i think it's
uh you know the media space has been
something that i've been enjoying and uh
you know i've done a handful of these
and and i'm not sure if i if i've told
you you know thank you for for having me
on here
yeah yeah yeah it's always a ton of fun
to get together yeah always a ton of fun
to get together and chat but
yeah you know i think it's it's a chance
to
uh a chance to scale a little bit
because you know on
in the day job you know you get the the
one-on-one interaction
yeah um but uh you know uh with one
too many yeah that's right right you get
you you
you're able with information technology
to touch such a greater
uh greater greater population uh that's
that's that's powerful yeah even that
little kind of like
boop boop boop breakdown of lasik in
30 seconds or cataracts and
i think is super insightful for people
and it's kind of a big part of the
future especially with immersion into
more of the those virtual reality
pedagogies that we are talking about i
have
um and i like how you talk about it like
a
like a diverse portfolio in a sense of
abilities and like you want to be able
to be like that that's really important
so that's a good sort of recommendation
also to physicians
i like that a lot so the two
the two last thoughts one of them's uh
metaphysical and one of them is more
uh playful the metaphysical one is
what is the telos
what's the end state what is the god
head
where is our complex civilization
like a swarm intelligence evolving
towards
what is the attractor that we're going
towards
i know i know how much you love this
and i love it i love it for you
um you know
it it's funny we uh yeah maybe
you know the uh the the medical folks
you know they
we get a little granular
you know so the on some of the this
open-ended
i feel like i feel like it's like you
you like open the door
to like this wild prairie and you're
like go
you're free now that uh like go run away
like now you can now you can go run um
and uh and i'm just like looking out the
door like
where do you want me to go yeah you know
but i was kind of comfy in here you know
i liked it here
like you can close the door it's fine we
don't have to go anywhere it's nice and
warm in here you know
[Music]
does that does does that answer your
question oh that's so
great
that's so great yeah the power of a
question to sort of take us
from that comfy cozy like
individual to something that's a little
bit more
cosmic is really powerful
and it can drive
a deep amount of
of feelings of awakening
to the unity of all being in existence
it can
drive awe
and enlightenment and a lot of really
important
underrepresented s traits
in modernity that are also
potentially the root of all of our
maladies
being that some of the people in the
positions of the greatest power on the
planet
haven't undergone said
augmentations in their being
and so that's why the power of those
questions is so rich what would what
would you say would be an attractor have
you heard of
that conversation that i've had
on the program and what i have in the
high-level perception where i talk about
it being like the metaverse
so like the synthesis of artificial
general intelligence
indistinguishable virtual realities and
bio and neurotech like neuralink
all together in some metaverse and so
the idea being that in a couple of
decades
we are immersing ourselves into these
indistinguishable virtual worlds
for 80 years at a time and then
we forget that we made those immersions
into those virtual worlds and then we
realized that
that's what this is and so that would be
sort of how potentially a
one infinite creator
god source could continuously
eternally or infinitely explore
all possible phenomenology through this
style of transcension
going inward what do you think about
something like that
being the attractor
you know i i i'll even take this to a
different analogy you know
this this would be like you know like
going in the pool
um and uh and then swimming
swimming out like you know like hey i'm
gonna i'm gonna take this
ophthalmologist
out in the deep end um and uh and we're
gonna pull him out over here and like
you know because
i'm like six three six four right let's
pull him out just where he can't touch
um you know just just to where he can't
touch and then
like let's and then let's leave him and
watch him splash around a little bit
that uh
it's it's really meant to sort of
like i thought your analogy was going to
be something that's a good one and then
like if you're
swimming in the pool and then all of a
sudden you
you know you open the pool and it just
opens up into the ocean into like the
middle of the ocean
yeah there's another sort of way to to
view that but
that's sort of the beauty of this
like you know when somebody becomes
interested
even in that question at a deeper level
do you have thoughts around the
attractor
of what we're evolving towards
i mean i think my um
my hope you know would be that you know
we're moving towards
um and you know and maybe this year ends
up being
uh you know a jump start to some of that
right where maybe this year as as
everybody's
you know been forcibly removed from
their
standard life from you know business as
usual is not usual anymore
um and you know maybe we are a little
bit more intentional about how
how we treat each other how we listen um
you know
what our what our intentions are for
our family for our neighbors for our
community
uh you know maybe you know maybe things
are able to to come back in a way that
that is a little bit more
uh pro
each other yeah i like that a lot
which is ultimately what
self-realization does is
you realize that you transcend
the i other and you realize that
unity that oneness and it
when you get to such states of
non-duality
you begin architecting everything that
you do
from that knowing and that's why
everything you do
is of the highest morality at that point
you see
sentience itself at a very macro level
and when you do that you see it
potentially as some sort of like a mind
and that's why i specifically
like you know like you talked about a
moment ago it's
it's not just the that
state of mirror consciousness
on the program for the guest
to shine and blossom and to navigate the
breadths and depths
of that but it's also to try and distill
the most profound realizations of the
guess
that i'm sponging up into these graphics
and visuals
and in this case it would be something
like that
one begins understanding sentience
itself
is it awareness and consciousness is it
and if we think about it like
a brain with the nerve endings
themselves
that sentience
acts as nerve endings within its own
creation
and then we experience it
phenomenologically
and we sort of can potentially integral
we can have an integration of the qualia
like the summation
of the experiences and that is just this
one
creation and so it's really important
the
the integration is like the integral in
the sense of
biologically speaking we are 99.9
genetically similar
and the derivation the derivative the
individuation is like the
0.1 genetic difference that's like your
unique
gift or your unique north star so it's
not just to say that
all that exists is some unity ocean
because that's a very
in a sense a it
de-sacralizes the beauty of the
individual
artistic expression and so you have to
you have to bring those two together
which is basically what
this graphic that i
wrap with is about which is the
in chapter 10 on infinity which is
basically
that synthesis humans find themselves as
the portal we are portals where on one
side we live
in that spiritual non-dual symphonic
state and on the other side we live in
this physi
physical individual solo state and the
solo in the symphony
is your unique instrument your unique
melody that you play
which is what you're doing ophthalmology
is your
unique instrument your unique melody and
avid sailor and surfer
yeah so i actually thought that was more
spiritual
yeah really yeah
yeah i mean also the way you describe
ophthalmology is spiritual because you
describe it from a science merging with
art
perspective you get it yeah you get it
in many ways
last question is the silly question
which is what is your favorite food
um ooh i wasn't ready for that one
what is my favorite food um
sushi might be sushi yeah bro
it's so good i just had some sushi
yesterday tell me more about
recency bias yeah yeah yeah
i was like what did you eat yesterday
sushi yeah that's my favorite uh
you know love takeout uh i got a little
spot like maybe like three blocks from
my place
um does great take out bento boxes 25
bucks
can't beat it what's your
go-to sushi what's your favorite
to pack inside and on top of the rolls
um so i like the rules or are you are
you nigiri
guy i i don't quite do the sashimi i
don't know i like the rice you know
so so i do um while you know
as much as i would love to be like a
purist right like
drink your whiskey neat um eat your
sushi sashimi only
like right there yeah but you know the
uh uh i typically do do nigiri you know
i like the the salmon the yellow tail
little eel is good yeah you know it's
uh it's good stuff yeah
oh cool and then um
i would also like to say that uh do you
have a specific
uh additional like drink of choice
or a uh like a beverage of choice
do you have one of those as well this is
my first time walking into the beverage
of choice
the beverage
i i do i really drink a lot of coffee
yeah coffee is the go-to yeah you know i
do um
coffee uh kombucha iced tea
yeah yeah that's like that's like my
trifecta what's your go-to
on those three like what brand of coffee
so i i've got like a nice little i
actually get some of the uh
you know you know bezos and
and his and his amazonification right of
the world
yeah you know i get i get a shipment in
on sundays yeah um
and uh i get these like little uh the
cold starbucks cold brew
oh those little nitro cold brews yeah
yeah i do one without the one that's
black
black yeah yeah likewise those nitro
cold brews are solid yeah right
yeah nice they're in the fridge you
start the day with it
uh um you know a little kombucha with
lunch a little iced tea after work
uh and uh and we start again tomorrow
yeah well that's cool
interesting interesting
yeah wow what a what an epic
what an epic show what an epic show
we made it yeah and also
the the coverage was excellent like the
coverage
of breadth the breadth of it was
excellent but also
we really got into those depths and i'm
really glad that we had those visuals
they were super instrumental
and it's quite obvious that
you're well versed and we needed to do
this episode
not only to highlight you and highlight
the beauty of your unique
flower blossoming but also the field of
ophthalmology in general
is super important to highlight
you know it's crazy to think that
there's less than 20 000
ophthalmologists in the us and that
there's
you know 3.6 million people that in the
us that are undergoing cataracts
surgeries every single year and 700 000
undergoing lasik
and like it really makes you sort of
like especially when you understand more
about perception and vision and
it just makes you more in love with the
eye just this general conversation
should make you more in love with the
eye
um well both this eye
and the eye and um
and it should also give us gratitude for
the fact that we don't have
um that cataracts yet and that we should
be grateful for that and that we should
also build the tools and the strategies
that
enable us to um retain that youthful
homeostatic capacity for prolonged
periods of time
correct some of the perverse incentives
in the industry
rocket into more physician
entrepreneurship
merge science and art together there
were a lot of really critical
yeah takeaways and explorations from the
program no it's uh yeah i'm grateful to
be a part of it i really am thank you
and grateful for
for sharing this with you thank you
thank you thanks
alex thank you everyone for tuning in as
well we greatly appreciate you we'd love
to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking
let us know how you're feeling let us
know how you understood some of the
concepts
that alex was teaching just throw some
of your
comments below and check out the links
in the bio below both alex's instagram
profile
as well as his youtube page go and give
him a follow go give him a subscribe
and follow up on the awesome content
that
he's posting there and
also like the video subscribe if you
haven't share the video with people that
you think would this would resonate with
with ophthalmology
especially if you have loved ones that
need to know more details about what
exactly
uh is happening in that space of
cataracts and lasik and things like that
and also support the artists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders
scientists entrepreneurs
engineers in your communities and around
the world that you believe in support
them and help them flourish you can find
all of our links in the bio below to
simulation you can help us continue
executing all of our biggest streams
here as well
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in
thank you we'll see you soon
peace
back